Why we really love thinking about these sort of things? This option is not right.
The reason this is not right is this has no electric field anywhere.
Clearly, if I put a positive charge in the middle somewhere,
it will go to the right towards the negative charge so that can't be right.
There must be some electric field, but on this one, this one has a weird shape.
According to this one, if I put a charge here, it would fill a force upwards, it looks like.
Now, that doesn't make sense. It should be attracted more towards the negative charge.
There's no reason for to go up so that's wrong. These two look very similar.
It's just the matter of what they point to the positive or point towards the negative,
and the correct answer is they should point towards the negative.
One thing that's really interesting is to look at the strength of the electric field
and how we see that with these pictures.
So for example, right between these two charges, the field would be very strong.
You can see there's a high density of field lines here.
In this one little drawing I made, this little shape, three field lines have gone through.
They are all tightly packed together. Tightly packed field lines mean a strong field.
Way out over here, I can draw a similar area, and no field lines are going through.
The electric field would be very weak over here.